noi siamo per oggi
nella scorsa puntata abbiamo parlato di
sesso avventurandoci in quella della
geografia della nudità e sa come questa
si adatta in relazione all'intimità e al
lavoro ci siamo chiesti cosa nascondiamo
sotto i vestiti oggi vogliamo parlare di
quello che nascondiamo sotto la pelle la
mente ma da questa presentazione dico
che ti sei svegliato molto a scriverla
per affrontare una tematica così basta
avremo bisogno dell'aiuto di mattia cis
psicologo e psicoterapeuta solitamente
abituato a farle lui le domande ma oggi
gliele faremo noi questa però non era
mia quando aich dob proprio allora nome
mattia cis professione psicologo e
psicoterapeuta ha fondato con mauro
orsini psicologi online una piattaforma
dove per trovare uno psicologo a portata
di click è specializzato in niger gip
istituto per lo studio e la ricerca dei
disturbi psichici puoi dire anche in
inglese
jordi ai playoff
che fai chex sapin
presso la scuola di specializzazione in
psicoterapia breve integrata quando c'è
il seminario annuale lavorare sui sogni
attraverso l'uso di tecniche cognitive
allora io vorrei dire che la puntata di
oggi secondo me si sposa perfettamente
con quella che è stata la mia mattinata
sono arrivate in ritardo infatti chiedo
scusa ai miei illustri colleghi musica
ma ne è successo una cosa che secondo me
apre in maniera perfetta la puntata di
oggi
io ho una sveglia con la canzone di adel
è giusto per iniziare popolaccio
arrivata travagliati
con giusto passo quella no quella
[Musica]
mamma
la rotella conosci allora ebbe
abbastanza famosa questa canzone da
cantare
ecco io non mi ha lasciata lì 2008 il
secondo
che impazza erano
urne il cuore non ha mai detto a delta è
comunque è successa una cosa particolare
non mi sono svegliato ma in compenso ho
sognato di cantarla sul palco con lei ha
quindi questa zona è un teatro amendola
introiettato secondo me pur di non farmi
svegliare la cosa scusa la mia mente la
lo ha introiettato
sembravano
io introietta tante cose
l'occasione vogliamo parlare allora con
il nostro ospite riess facciamo
l'entrare facciamo introiettare a
costituirsi amoni 6 milioni ma chi a
buongiorno benvenuto dottore non so io
non so mai come appellarmi alle figure
che al contrario mio hanno studiato
nella vita hanno scelto di avere a me
non è mai chiesto esultare anche in
lingue per l'impresa
stiamo scherzando
no e guliano però comunque dottor gallo
ve lo giuro su dio ve lo giuro chi siamo
noi per smentire un giuramento sui testi
girare almeno su un qualcosa di reale è
comunque da d'ora in poi chiamami
dottore io forse partirà con psicologo e
psicoterapeuta psicologa bisogna dare
una gara non è una distinzione chiara
per tutti
possiamo dirla alla psicoterapia la cia
io no love interrogo lo psicologo ha
conseguito una laurea anche può essere
triennale o anche quinquennale con la
specializzazione ma non può praticare la
psicoterapia mettiamocelo psicoterapeuta
poi si fa un altro buco di culo di altri
4 anni alì specializzazione interno dei
quali viene psicanalizzato lui stesso
nel frattempo studia uno dei metodi
cognitivi e si allena si allena si è
allenata ma si allena finché a un certo
punto non viene buttato nel mondo come
un piccolo colibrì dopo nove anni di
studio per insomma ragazzi e tirocini
nel servizio pubblico gestire la testa
degli altri è comunque un qualcosa che
bisogna fare quei guanti di velluto cosa
ti ha spinto a intraprendere questo
percorso quello che in realtà spinge
tantissimi miei colleghi io insegno
anche no quindi vedo tanti psicologi che
diventano terapeuti e mi raccontano le
loro storie
noi siamo prima di tutto dei pazienti
nel senso che abbiamo delle nostre
sofferenze delle nostre fatiche venoste
difficoltà delle nostre storie di vita e
forse mettiamo in priorità la capacità
di uscirne
e se diventi terapeuta ti aspetti che in
qualche modo riuscire a star meglio no
quindi secondo me la prima motivazione
pressare benevento e stesso poi è vero
che fin da piccolo cercavo di fare i
test mi piacevano un sacco mi piace un
sacco come funziona il cervello quindi
c'è anche un aspetto suoi più ludico
conoscitive ma se posso parlarti a cuore
aperto dire così l'ho fatto per me ma
nel momento in cui però tu recepisce
così tante informazioni no immagino che
comunque ti arriveranno dei racconti un
po più leggeri altri invece un pochino
più pesanti qual è la dinamica con cui
comunque tu riesci a fare scudo
cioè io per dire quando qualcuno gli
parla di una cosa impegnativa come
quello se ci arriva alla sera che tipo
assorbito quella cosa no tu come la
gestisce questa cosa deve un po
proteggerti dove però proteggersi non
significa mettere uno scudo uno schermo
no anzi il contrario la terapia un
incontro di persone che entrano in
empatia quindi le emozioni del terapeuta
il mio sguardo il volto ad esempio è
molto importante il tono della voce
devono entrare in sintonia col paziente
per poterlo curare per poterlo
accogliere quindi devi un po limitare
forse numero di persone oppure stare
attento su alcuni temi magari nella tua
storia tu
hai avuto un'esperienza negativa
traumatica quel paziente ti porta quel
problema se magari tu non l'hai ancora
ben elaborato forse quel paziente meglio
non prenderlo
quindi devi essere molto consapevole di
quali sono i tuoi problemi quali sono le
tue difficoltà e poi l'altro elemento è
che in fondo se di per dare una mano
quindi tu mi puoi raccontare anche la
cosa più brutta che sia capitata e
ovviamente io lavoro solo su questo
ma io ho la tranquillità di sapere che
tu ne uscirai la salute mentale è ancora
una una forma di salute invisibile noi
oggi vogliamo veramente fare un viaggio
all'interno della mente secondo te quali
possono essere gli strumenti per tori
per toglie per abbattere sicuramente lo
stigma sulla psicologia ma soprattutto
quello che poi si porta dietro cioè lo
stigma anche su quella che poi il valore
della salute mentale
sono perfettamente d'accordo e se sono
qui anche per questo no infatti vi
ringrazio tantissimo perché storicamente
non ci pensi dai tempi della psicanalisi
è sempre stato così c'è il terapeuta che
si riparte nasce addirittura con i
notisti no conservco prima di freud è
quella roba che fa una magia che tu non
capisci bene che avviene nell'aria non
lo strizzacervelli
fa lui qualcosa no e tu se sul lettino e
non capisci no quindi a una professione
esoterica storicamente adesso invece no
stiamo cercando di fare il contrario
quindi anche con la nostra pagina
instagram degli psicologi on line in
qualsiasi modo cerchiamo di spiegare in
maniera semplice cosa vuol dire andare
in terapia cosa si fa in terapia quando
si va in terapia il concetto è certo che
esistono i matti mentali e non è un tabù
parlarne anzi c'è niente di male anche
nell'aver n'è uno insomma
niente ma allo stesso tempo il messaggio
mi piacerebbe mandare anche dallo
psicologo si può andare per qualsiasi
ragione non ci sono ragioni troppo
stupidi o superficiali per andare in
terapia ti aggiungo una cosa perché m
negli ultimi anni mi è capitato molto di
parlare insomma di salute mentale e così
via una cosa che ho notato e magari tu
me la matita sci a smentire oppure ad
esserne d'accordo è che adesso dicevate
no non è un limite dire che una malattia
mentale quando si parla di salute
mentale se c'è un problema di salute
mentale come se questo problema fosse
attaccato un senso di colpa
cioè se vedi qualcuno con un braccio
rotto gli dici mi dispiace se vedi
qualcuno con la depressione è pigro o
come esatto è come se dicessi perché è
arrivato a quel punto no
un esercizio che io credo si possa fare
poi magari ha solo una paranoia mi ha
completamente esagerata e moralistica
però i social delle volte esagerano sul
liquidare un problema quante volte è
capitato di dire oggi sono depresso oggi
ho l'ansia e tu questa cosa non la
diresti mai per dire oggi il cancro
perché ti guarderebbero ma si sa che è
rispettoso che si può essere una cosa
che aiuta cioè dare un'importanza medica
delle parole che invece oggi usiamo come
per dire sto un po triste quello dipende
forse anche da come vivono le persone
che hanno la depressione quando qualcun
altro dice oggi sono depressi sono
perché appunto potrebbe essere uno
svilire secondo me dobbiamo essere in
diritto di dire come ci sentiamo noe se
quella parola rappresenta per noi quel
vissuto possiamo dirla non voglio
mettermi nella condizione di renault è
importante
se il mal di testa puoi dire che il mal
di testa non poi magari la causa di come
la di testa può essere anche una
patologia grave io volevo chiederti ma a
ai più pazienti giovani o
un po più adulti perché secondo me
vorrei spezzare una lama favore
una dispensa
lancia una lancia scusate è dottore
comunque secondo me adesso lo stigma del
andare dallo psicologo queste cose qua
tra i giovani è un po sperato nel senso
ma perché mi guardi a me
lo sguardo verso di te e adulto da che
da giusto per capire
l'anno dopo il mio ok quindi noi siamo
già la generazione con lo stinco
sbagliato l'anno dopo il mio cioè qui in
tutte le persone più giovani no noi
siamo decadi dopo di lui con la domanda
secondo te qual è il male oggi ad oggi a
livello concreto c'è un qualcosa che ti
torno che vedi più spesso le persone
quello che mi aspetto di vedere e che
nei fatti si sta vedendo molto è quella
cosa che possiamo chiamare l'insicurezza
no che non è un termine come diagnostico
no e che però che fare tanto con il
proprio valore con la percezione del
proprio valore della propria autostima e
della propria identità nel mondo del
gioco e mondo virtuale come nel mondo di
un social come instagram
io posso costruirmi d'identità che
scelgo di far vedere però poi questo può
creare delle grandi aree di insicurezza
e
quello che anche stiamo vedendo sono le
difficoltà relazionali cioè le persone
fanno molta fatica
a innamorarsi a costruire una relazione
a vivere il limite che l'altro comporta
a portare i propri bisogni nella
relazione
c'è grande fatica su questo punto si può
creare anche un ulteriore livello di
frustrazione personale dove non solo tu
non vali niente come persona o comunque
delle forti insicurezze reali e
tangibili ma all'interno di quel mondo
che pensi invece per un pochino compreso
anche il telecomando si che non vuoi
prenderti della grande sberle
infatti vorrei parlare poi più avanti
magari serviva anche di consigli
concreti anche radici ratici danza anche
più sei famoso peggio è no io non ho un
termine di paragone perché da quando
sono i soci oi social però il mio
problema è che sono fondamentalmente
diventato fu vulnus famoso nel momento
in cui ho aperto i social e quindi non
mi rendo conto di qual è un utilizzo sta
io cioè potessi scegliere per la mia
vita cioè io so che non avrei
l'approccio sui social perché non ho
proprio
l'abilità la voi ha la mentalità di
turno graf ha l'istinto di fotografare
una cosa caricarla per farla vedere a
chi cioè io ai miei gruppi di whatsapp
con le persone della mia vita dove ci
scambiamo
l'inferno e quello per me è sufficiente
per la condivisione quindi non ho il
senso della vita lisco moltissimo ti
capisco tantissimo io poi ho vissuto
anche molto male per esempio nel mio
caso il coming out cioè inizialmente non
potevo farlo e quindi liberamente quello
ciò che mostrava online era diverso da
ciò che ero ciò che mi sentivo di essere
nel momento in cui poi c'era un
ossessione nei confronti di quella
particolare roba legato a me una volta
fatto il coming out io ho cercato in
tutti i modi anzi di abbattere la
versione reale la versione virtuale cioè
mi faccio schifo come persona un botto
di difetti numeri conoscerlo per con i
fans fai silenzio
hai detto che lo te ne frega niente
sempre fermo non me ne frega niente però
la cosa positiva secondo me da questo
punto di vista è che a me va bene che ti
sta sul cazzo ma guarda questa è proprio
la base una delle basi della felicità
cioè il fatto che quello che noi siamo
non è scollato
dalle aspettative che gli altri hanno su
di noi e dal fatto che noi possiamo
totalmente fregarsene di queste
aspettative tullo invece com'è che la
vivi i social sì ma allora d'autore
grazie
io
abbastanza bene nel senso
scusa pensavo avessimo i contenuti
no posso parlare lasciamo parlare il
mondo dei social secondo me soprattutto
dove metto i video su si tocca è più
cioè non ci sono tante critiche per
leggere ronfi è molto più leggero
secondo me rispetto a youtube e queste
cose qua che la gente proprio a un
accanimento assurdo su tik tok ti fanno
i complimenti e quando devono ti
scrivono delle critiche ci sono tutti
gli altri utenti che ti difendono e e
forse anche troppo c'è magari qualcuno
cerca di fare un complimento ma magari
risulta non troppo complimento e strutto
quindi boccia questa cosa qua che
bisogna essere sempre buoni sono molto
fedeli sito e followers si proteggono
spero di sì
voglio insultarti sui tic toc
scoprire i
ragazzi vogliamo alleggerire un momento
questa chiacchiera per fare una cosa che
ci eravamo promessi un attimo all'inizio
lo vedo l'ora giusta di che cosa stiamo
parlando
parliamo prima dei suoni si stiamo
parlando di loro i sogni sono la terapia
del nostro cervello quindi quando noi
sogniamo nella fase rem di una famosa
fase in cui gli occhi si muovono in
maniera veloce è una sequenza di fasi ne
sono quattro cinque fasi è una di queste
non è lultima quindi si alternano nel
sonno quella fase ii è la fase in cui
nostro cervello sta rielaborando tutte
le memorie della giornata le mette
insieme con le memorie del passato e le
rielabora livello emotivo quindi noi
sogniamo sempre suoniamo tutte le notti
anche se non te lo ricordi hai sognato e
questa è la vera terapia che nostro
cervello fa
se noi durante il giorno possiamo
prendere un pezzettino di questo sogno e
aiutare il cervello a lavorarci tanto
meglio parlerò di questo sogno che
ho fatto più volte
ok sogno ricorrente esatto allora
praticamente
io cambia anche tono mentre ero in
questo luogo serio stranissimo tipo
strano proprio non più niente c'erano
dei cubi e io devo fare da un cubo
all'alto per raggiungere tipo una fine
al di là non lo so
e ogni volta che arrivavo verso l'uscita
tipo qualcuno veniva e mi spingeva giu
pezzo di merda
cadendo giù finiva in questo passo tutto
buio e mi rendevo conto che ero in
questo posto buio però stavola c'è fisso
e come ti senti bili normale come senso
c'è sarei voluto andare su ok però non
riuscivo a raggiungerlo c'erano e che
cercavo di salire stavola e giravo per
ora tutto buio quinto stai dicendo in un
percorso che c'è un ostacolo che viene
dall'esterno nei ghetti butta giù esatto
che ti ricorda qualcosa nella tua vita
capita a volte di sentirti giu qualcuno
ti butti giù che qualcosa ti butti giù e
che invece che a reagire e trovare
magari di risorse stai un po lì è
capitato quindi se fossi mio paziente
cercherà di capire quando è nato questo
sogno ricorrente perché vuol dire che è
qualcosa che il tuo cervello non ancora
del tutto ben capito rielaborato no e
quindi lui cerca di farlo è una
questione su cui si deve ancora lavorare
magari ti chiederei come modifiche resti
sogno quindi da sveglio perché non
proviamo a immaginare invece un finale
diverso e cosa ti impedisce di
realizzare un finale diverso come
possiamo aiutare quel ragazzo che ti nel
buio che ci fa anche un po tenerezza non
certo noi non vogliamo lasciarlo lì
quindi dobbiamo prenderlo per mano e
tirarlo su e capire perché lui non ce la
fa da solo a farlo wow io sognavo da
piccolo quando ancora abitavo nella mia
vecchia casa di volare ma il mio volo
non è mai stato tipo goku cioè non è mai
stato superman il mio volo partiva
sempre come un grande sforzo iniziale di
nuoto per riuscire a prendere il volo
per cui inizialmente c'era una mega
fatica mega fatica mega fatica mag a
fatica poi pian piano bravo quasi come
alle riusciva allontanandomi dalla
diciamo dal terreno allora riuscivo a
essere più leggero saper preacher finché
non potevo planare anche a 100 200 metri
di distanza guardando la mia vita in
prospettiva e che sensazione avevi una
volta che ero su dicevo cavolo era
bellissimo era bellissimo e la cosa che
io ricordo sempre che mi domandavano il
sogno è sto sognando non sto sognando so
io sogno o son desto perché quello che
ricordavo era che quella capacità era un
qualcosa che in realtà volevo anche
nella vita st è raggiunto nella tua vita
quella capacità di volare con
quell'energia e a quella quota allora in
questo momento non so dirtelo i denari
giro secondo me io ho iniziato in realtà
nella vita non aver bisogno più di
dovermi allontanare troppo da quella
casa ho imparato a volare con i piedi
per terra
cioè la lavoro un po ti prego se ci
scrive un pezzo mi è piaciuta a grava
sereno i ragazzi non ne ho io non ho mai
fatto sogni ricorrenti ho una
grandissima difficoltà a ricordarmi cosa
sogni a un sonno molto profondo lo zero
frequenti risvegli tantissimi hanno
disturbato d'altissimo diciamo che c'è
un quarto d'ora di tempo prima che la
traccia del ricordo del sonno svanisca
quindi il sogno va ricordato è fissato
subito devi avere l'intenzione di
ricordartelo perché se tu non hai
intenzione di farlo ti disgrazia ma
prima di dormire si si
ad esempio con la tuba in terapia ci
sono pazienti che non si ricordano mai
soli no poi io tutte le volte chiedo
questa settimana è segnato qualcosa
no no no e poi iniziano a sognare no
perché portano l'attenzione al sogno
perché mese ogni cielo ad occhi aperti
io non so se se mi sta scappando la
cacca o se un principio di ragazzi
comunque qual è il tuo consiglio a chi
si affaccia oggi a internet ea chi
quotidianamente riceve bullismo diciamo
minorenne deve essere protetto dagli
adulti 15 devono essere gli educatori e
genitori ai quali rivolgersi il
maggiorenne deve trovare un modo per
gestire dentro di lui l'impatto di
questa critica dobbiamo trovare dentro
di noi la capacità di proteggersi a me
viene in mente sempre questa metafora
della membrana cioè noi abbiamo una
membrana intorno a noi questa membrana
viene toccata dalle cose esterne però la
nostra membrana non deve farlo entrare
quindi noi dobbiamo decidere quello che
vogliamo far entrare e quello che
dobbiamo lasciare fuori e trovare questa
capacità di proteggere nosta identità
nostro mondo interno quando ricevevo
magari dei commenti di bullismo violenti
cattivi in realtà mi vergognavo in
quanto invece è importante riuscire a
uscire da quella dinamica quasi come se
te lo meritasse o quasi come se fosse
una colpa stessa ricevere un insulto e
parlarne intanto la vergogna ha una
funzione sociale importantissima c'è
bisogna prima capire a cosa serve la
vergogna perché serve proprio a mettersi
in una posizione di sottomissione al
gruppo quindi non devi accusati di aver
provato vergogna perché è normale e
serve a sopravvivere in quel gruppo non
perché sia proprio vergogna allora tu mi
accetterai mi metto in sottomissione e
non sarà buttato fuori dal gruppo quindi
quella reazione nord poi però devo
andare in un altro gruppo di persone che
vi vogliono bene quindi può essere la
famiglia possono essere i miei amici in
cui posso dire quello che mi è successo
e fare un'esperienza diversa cioè che
quello che io sono va bene per te in
maniera tale che le esperienze positive
possano compensare formative ma io ho
avuto la stessa cosa sul bullismo per
dire cioè io ho accettato il fatto che
ero vittima di bullismo ma tanto dopo
cioè in realtà pochi anni fa io ho
capito che quello che per me era la
normalità in realtà era un atto di
bullismo
cioè se tu mi chiedevi in fase
adolescenziale se vittima di bullismo e
ti dicevo che reese bagliato tu non loro
è il collega o proprio c'è mi ero
riscritto un sistema valoriale che non
era a perché una cerca di sopravvivere
cioè se io penso di essere sbagliato mi
adatterò quindi cercherò di fare
qualcosa per andare incontro agli altri
quindi è funzionale se io sono una
famiglia dove in e genitori litigano e
si picchiano e si tirano le cose e io mi
metto mi rendo invisibile quello è
funzionale perché mi proteggo però poi
nella vita magre da adulto avrò la
sensazione che io non ho il diritto ad
esistere ad avere il mio spazio no
quindi quello che magari era funzionale
quando è nato perché se tu ti fossi
esposto magari sarebbero stati ancora
più cattivi poi ti rimane come un
apprendimento che va istinto va cambiato
perché poi nella vita è avuta non serve
più mentre invece quando a essere
toccata
è una persona a noi vicina immagino che
so sono un papà non sto diventando
soprattutto zio però mio nipote io un
domani vorrei in qualche modo riuscire
ad aiutarlo nella almeno nel trovare un
posto sicuro in mente esistono secondo
teso che è veramente
molto analizzare anche il consiglio però
esistono dei delle azioni che si possono
fare concretamente per avere un rapporto
di fiducia perché mi sembra che se
bambini è facile per un momento in cui è
intanto deve spendere del tempo di
qualità con questo di pochino o nipotina
no quindi i parenti su importantissimi
perché la famiglia ha un nucleo che a
volte molto rigido il mio consiglio è mi
raccomando fai delle esperienze positive
e passa del tempo in maniera naturale
con questa persona e prova a stabilire
un rapporto per cui le cose che ti può
chiedere tre può chiedere senza pensare
che sarà giudicato o anche potendo
pensare a come tu che puoi rapportare a
questa persona in maniera diversa come
fanno i suoi genitori
certo e soprattutto di fronte a
qualsiasi vissuto perché a volte un
bambino ti dice io ho paura del buio e
il genitore banalizza questa cosa perché
a va nel buio non c'è niente se ho
capito ma è un vissuto che lui porta e
lo rappresenta attraverso questa
immagine quindi se tu banalizzi non
rispecchi il vissuto dell'altro ma anche
da adulti e dobbiamo tutti avere questo
rispetto in qualche modo lo disconosce e
dici che quello che lui e non va bene
quindi è importantissimo come quando
bambino ti porta un disegno che realtà
non scarabocchi tu dici a e meraviglioso
non capolavoro
se ti portano emozioni un vissuto un
pensiero dobbiamo accettarlo per quello
che è senza mettere in discussione solo
perché per noi non è così l'empatia
quella roba di cioè non è che deve
essere successo anche a me per capirti
mi basta la tua emozione le emozioni di
base sono cinque quindi
la gioia la rabbia e la tristezza la
paura l'abbiamo provata a tutti questo
napoli vinse doubt anche il disgusto c'è
sono quelle liete del massimo come mar
io da bambino va beh
alle medie sono stato abbastanza
abilitato
però mi sono reso conto
che sono scappato da quel da
quell'ambito sono ho cambiato scuola e
però è stato un
un percorso effettivo giudicato un sacco
anche dai miei genitori anche se in
realtà non è stato così assolutamente
però era c'è stato pesanti andare
un'altra realtà
e con la paura di ritrovarlo il nostro
essere capitato è però per fortuna
andato tutto bene stavo talmente non è
che stavo male però sentivo proprio
tanta pressione addosso
tutti questi miei compagni che di classe
che non è che si focalizzavano tutti su
di me però c'erano quelle bombe e
comunque
le tue chiesti tutti i genitori qui gli
ho detto io non ce la faccio più voglio
bravo è secondo me però ci sono tante
persone cioè tanti famiglie c'era un
altro ragazzino in un'altra classe che
poverino veniva utilizzato ancora peggio
ma la mia domanda è in questo caso è nei
cieli non è che sono scappato però mi
sono allontanato da quell'ambiente
negativo è meglio affrontarlo o
allontanarsi dipende dalle situazioni se
è una situazione che tu puoi cambiare
mantenendo vivi diciamo i tuoi bisogni
quindi posso realizzarmi come studente
anche da un'altra parte e quell'ambiente
un ambiente nocivo tossico
posso anche allontanarmene chiedere una
cosa io perché adesso stiamo facendo già
un po di puntate la prima puntata in cui
parliamo solo di noi in realtà bello ti
succede spesso questo nella vita un po
sì come gestisci questa cosa che la
verità personalizzata sì un po sì
diciamo che a volte forse anche una
posizione per me di sicurezza quindi mi
sono abituato a non parlare quindi
parlato e riesco a trovare un'alleanza
con l'altro su questo è uno strumento
che mi permette di sentirmi al sicuro
con l'altro
poi ovvio ai miei amici con cui parlo a
fondono
altre volte non lo vorreste una volta mi
è capitato che ho chiamato un taxi e non
so come mai ma gli è uscito proventi da
google il mio nome conflitto psicologo
finora
messo nella salito sul taxi ma lei è
psicologo urlato e tutto il viaggio che
era anche un pochino lungo mi ha
raccontato insomma tutta la sua storia
di vita e 20 minuti e poi voleva la
soluzione con clemente che è così in due
secondi quelli entry lo pagavo
un'arma a doppio taglio abbiamo parlato
ovviamente di
di problematiche di difficoltà
secondo te invece qual è la chiave per
mantenere voglio finire così in app per
mantenere un un momento bello nella
propria vita non so se questa domanda mi
trova in sintonia perché tipo ti spiego
mi essere tristi o per stato difficile o
provare delle sensazioni negative
va bene no abbia detto che le emozioni
sono cinque se quindi vogliamo viverle
tutte 5 quindi a spese sempre felice
però solamente un'altra ok è quella
verde ok magari per come si è fatto tu
la gioia la felicità è la promozione
prevalente o quella che ti fa sentire
forte o capace non lo so però non
c'entri ma la star è quella tristezza
quindi forse l'obiettivo è come posso
star meglio con le mie emozioni negative
anche perché comunque dai ci sono dei
momenti in cui è bello esser triste
si dai non vi è mai capitato di dire ma
col senno del poi chiaramente che in
quel momento mentre lo vivi fa schifo
però poi passa e dc comunque se ora ci
penso un po nostalgia di quello stato di
coma scale no allora per me l'altro si è
mai successo per me la tristezza è una
brutta sensazione
non la rinnego però a volte per me la
tristezza ecco è un è un motore in
realtà per uscire a determinate
situazioni
quelle che più odio sono lira perché
proprio la rabbia non mi piace diventò
anche abbastanza antipatico vera non mi
avrebbe mai ma non tutte utili anche la
tristezza la presenza serve a fermarsi
un attimo e a capire cosa è andato
storto allora chiudiamo in app ragazzi
che ci sta ascoltando e ragazze fatelo
impianto no con le canzoni che il nonno
da piccolo mi diceva sempre questa cosa
che la peste se l'è portata via la
pioggia non il sole
sai che c'è la storia che la perde fu
[Musica]
sciacquata di sciacquata da giorni e
giorni e giorni di piogge milano mi
diceva sempre questa cosa l'ha portata
via dalla pioggia berna è un grande
siamo arrivati alla fine c'è un'ultima
cosa che ti che ti va di dire che
secondo te non è stato ha detto ultima
perla un concetto che vorresti ribadire
quello che vorrei ribadire io è se avete
bisogno andate dallo psicologo come si
fa andare dallo psicologo per chi ha
bisogno c'è il servizio pubblico quindi
abbiamo il diritto alla salute mentale e
lo psicologo è gratuito non sempre e non
in tutte le situazioni è facile averlo
però
ci sono gli psicologi privati ci sono i
siti internet noi abbiamo un sito
internet che si chiama di psicologia
online che anche una parte di colloqui
di solidarietà quindi si può venire si
può prenotare un colloquio
fate un primo incontro portate a tesi
quell'occasione da quelle opportunità
che dire grazie grazie mille
grazie grazie grazie michele deve essere
ovviamente avere io avrò in realtà la
schiena tatuata di aforismi di michele
bravi alla fine lei di suo nonno da oggi
non incredibile mattia davvero grazie di
comuni con generosità classe corazze
comunque ragazzi io c'è una cosa che mi
porto stasera a letto cosa a parte il
una sveglia diversa e va testato vedere
quello esatto grazie all ma io mi porto
il nuovo i beatles epiteto di lollo
barolo che dottor barolo per me adesso i
ragazzi è vero però vi giuro cioè sembra
assurdo perché comunque assolutamente
giovani che esso
sia già dottore ragazze la verità io ho
studiato ho messo ci ho messo un sacco
di sudore e ori ha ottenuto i risultati
ora comunque l'invidia
ragazzi non mi conveniva uniti file raw
raga è la verità che devo fare magari
più di questa puntata e secondo me e te
la porti a casa benissimo e sta zitto
ok ragazzi quindi siamo arrivati alla
fine della puntata ma il nostro viaggio
irregolare la scoperta dell'essere umano
non si ferma più
parlando di esteriorità di corpo e di
mente ma noi vogliamo andare ancora più
a fondo e provare ad addentrarci nel
mondo dell'invisibile
nella prossima puntata di feroce infatti
avremo come ospite una medium con la
quale parleremo di tutto
fino ad allora da noi feroce tutto
ragazzi e ragazze con grazia
[Risate]
ma che cos'è questa volta adesso di
partenza con si va ad espugnare
pornazzo
[Musica]